لقد كانت أفسس تجتذب الحشود منذ
آلاف
السنين، حيث كان تجميع جاذبية
الماضي هو عمل حياة مصطفى بانج، وقد
دخلنا الآن أكبر
كنيسة في غرب الأناضول بقياس 65
مترًا هنا يمكنك رؤية الحروف الأولى
للإمبراطور جستنيان الإمبراطور الذي بنى
هذا
المكان
بصفته عالم آثار شابًا، ساعد في
التنقيب عن كنيسة القديس يوحنا الضخمة
وكشف عن أدلة مهمة تربط
هذا الموقع بانتشار
المسيحية، وكان علينا العثور على إجابة
عن سبب بناء مثل هذه الكنيسة الكبيرة هنا.
الإجابة على هذا السؤال هي القبر الذي
يمكننا رؤيته
هنا يوجد قبر القديس يوحنا
أصغر رسل يسوع الذي
عهد إليه بأمه مريم العذراء،
يبدأ الحدث بأكمله بقبر القديس
يوحنا أحد الرسل الاثني عشر الأصليين،
يلعب يوحنا دورًا مهمًا في
المسيحية المبكرة لنشر الكلمة  بعد
موت يسوع في سفر الرؤيا،
أرسل يوحنا سبع رسائل إلى الكنائس
في المدن المحيطة يحث فيها
أتباعه الأوائل على السير في
طريق الله. نحن نقبل حقيقة أنه كتب
كتابه المقدس هنا أو هناك في القلعة
وأراد أن يُدفن.  هنا
أراد أن يكون قبره
[موسيقى]
هنا اليوم رسائل يوحنا هي خريطة طريق
للكثيرين الذين يقومون بالحج هنا إلى
تركيا الغربية
[موسيقى]
ومع ذلك فإن هذا المنزل الصغير في
التلال فوق أفسس هو الذي قد يجذب
مجموعة متنوعة من
[موسيقى]
يعتقد المؤمنون أنه المنزل الذي
قضت فيه مريم سنواتها الأخيرة، وهو عبارة عن
هيكل بسيط به
هالة قوية، في حين أن الكنيسة الكاثوليكية لم
تؤكد أو تنفي أبدًا ما إذا كانت والدة
يسوع عاشت بالفعل هنا، وقد زارها الكثير من
الباباوات إلى جانب عدد لا يحصى من الأشخاص.
الآخرون من جميع الأديان الذين يأتون للشهادة
واحترام بغض النظر عن الدين،
قد يكون الصفاء والهدوء الذي يحيط بهذا الموقع هو الكنز الحقيقي
[الموسيقى]